just off the southern tip of Manhattan
on New York's Governors Island an
unprecedented program is underway to
restore New York harbors once bountiful
oyster population and the environmental
benefits they bring it's called the
billion moister project what's more
amazing
it's an effort launched by students at
the New York Harbor school filmmakers
followed their progress for a year to
create the Discovery Channel documentary
take back the Harbor premiering on
Tuesday here's a preview growing up in
the Bronx I didn't know about the harbor
I got to know about the harbor once I
got to the school New York Harbor used
to be amazing dolphins used to be seen
in New York Harbor frequently and whales
we had sea horses that we were able to
see from the water we had seals we had
oysters that you can walk down on the
pier and just grab an oyster right out
of the harbor and you can eat it right
then and there
waster beds really were just what made
the Hudson River than the East River
such a hub of life boy stur is also they
filter like 50 gallons a day of water
it's a lot of water and that's pearl
oyster sure is a lot of water joining us
now are the documentaries co-director
Kristi Jacobson and recent Harvard
School Harbor school graduate Brian
Campbell good morning to you both so
glad you're here and I get to get up
extra early today for an 18 so Kristi
tell us how you even got involved and
interested in this yeah well a colleague
of ours that discovery had heard a
little piece on the radio about the
harbor school and my co-director Roger
Ross Williams and I arrived at Governors
Island to check it out and met Brian
among other students and just when we
saw them literally in action saving the
the harbor it just felt like it was
something we a story we really needed to
tell them and you spent an entire year
she yeah yeah so what we what we did is
we filmed over
over a school year but it's also like
the year of oyster restoration a lot of
different work can happen in the summer
obviously in the water diving under the
water and the winter and we filmed some
pretty major reefs being installed in
the water I'm amazed by this project
Brian I understand you vetoed your mom
I'm going to the harvester I didn't want
you to go it's not she imagined like a
tradition of a lawyer a doctor just say
no I'm gonna go to Harvey school yeah
how did you know about it what they were
doing um so I didn't know about like too
much into it
Mary Fisher the funder the harbor school
he came to come visit my junior high
school and I'll just like alright I'm
gonna put it down I put in my last
choice and I ended up getting in and I
wanted up likening what have you
actually been doing and regarding with
the oysters um so I'm in a vessel
operation so basically with the boats we
transport the oysters as well as the
other students like in aquaculture I
want to ask more hands-on with oysters
to the reef site but first
transportation we also do safety and I'm
navigation so we know how to get there
and everything he was driving the boats
that we were filming coming on yeah so
why were so many oysters
why was the oyster population depleted
and and how are you able to repopulate I
mean so the the New York Harbor was
literally once oyster capital of the
world
we ate them like crazy yeah we polluted
the waters and we dredged you know some
bigger ships could come through and all
of those things just kind of decimated
the oyster population when when this
project started like something like four
years ago there were almost zero wasters
allowed in the harbor yeah and and and
today thanks to the work of Brian and
and the other students will be an oyster
project there's 28 million and growing
Wow yeah be clear we are not to eat
these oysters good point yeah definitely
not Jewish specifically bread bread for
it like um clean up the harbor for
filtering and plus you want to eat a
likes a lot of New York Harbor that's
why our waster is so important what do
they do so they they filter the water so
they
an extraordinary amount yeah something
like 50 gallons a day gallons a day they
also provide storm protection and that's
a really important role that they can
play here in New York City
yeah and then also as the wreaths build
as they get created it creates like a
habitat for other underwater life so
it's they're really essential to
rebuilding the Harbor there are
gatekeepers really yeah yeah so right
now right I mean I live in New York no
until we just saw that clear Brian how
hard has it been to try to take on this
project as I'm a heart I do okay you
have everybody guiding you it's
definitely a big go so you kind of have
your doubts sometimes but I know we're
gonna get there it's really exciting
what you guys are doing yeah we're right
pattern Campbell thank you so much
Christie Jacobsen
really interesting doc you can remember
you can see take back to the harbor this
coming Tuesday December 19th on the
Discovery Channel Christie Brian thanks
again for coming I'm really interested